welcome to this video playing Hungarian
chess and this flag is irritating all on
Islands okay it's not playing it this is
some I think I like send a bad bet a bad
bad time yeah he's so living in Hungary
it seems originally from the US okay um
but kind of oh let's let's play
something else I rarely played okay so
we get to Kings Indian yeah I don't
really like the the modern type of
openings rather go to a king's indian
let's see what line is playing the
classical yes before before is the most
popular move probably really rose to
prominence in the late 1990s which is an
awful long time ago it still feels like
a relatively new development but already
for 15 years this has become the most
popular move to ok I played them 98
which isn't the most precise move at
least according to two most theoretical
sources this is some this some to set up
that you can kick Hikaru Nakamura
sometimes plays it leads to this some
very young sharp race type situations
where black pushes f45 and white really
gets ahead quickly on the queenside yes
yeah
I was briefly thinking Bishop age six or
something like that but let's just get
ad he's spending lots of time yes and
how on earth is it played this was 96
rukia fate yes i think it's a it's worth
taking right push up a three look here
and after be five yeah white um black
actually takes i'm not mistaken wow what
a position yeah this is some this is
real low testosterone chest like am just
yeah this is a chess equivalent of I
don't know or some kind of martial arts
where everything is allowed so white
already a broke through on the queenside
and I'm pushing here on the King side
I'm interesting now you can take here
take on c7 if it takes on c7 Queen takes
I'm taking this I can take with the rook
actually so I'm not not a big issue
question is how do I actually attack
should I play Bishop f8 or is it is it
too slow I'm not sure this position is
so sharp it's very very difficult to to
judge
it's not the exchange really that I'm
after I want to play work g7 and have
the look on the G file yeah I'm a bit
surprised that is not just taking I mean
putting it back looks really strange at
least to me I would have played g3 of
course on bishop f2 ok so let's see the
queen is not so bad on evade it's ready
to go to h6 for example is try to to to
push through her came
okay I cannot really allow him to take
on c7 i guess so i need to i need to
take take take a 6 doesn't look right
yeah but what what what else I need to I
need to do that probably okay night d 50
that's an interesting off using the rope
here yeah well this is all nice but how
do i do I get get to the king this is
not not a passive move per se the idea
yep he wants to take here right okay
what I'm what I what I want to do is
after G after h3 I want to say how can I
need to take probably all right i what
no not sure not sure actually what what
does the rook is not so important maybe
i can i can just give up the rook queen
this this this look is an important
attacking piece which is not so clear
for the a head rock so let's just do
that staking here okay so if i take
rookie 7 us may be the epic NTM you know
I can you to tell you to go down but one
else rookie sadness the problem he just
he just grabs my my attacking piece okay
I completely forgot about that one wow
yeah that's embarrassing that's
embarrassing I needed to take on edge to
first to at least make sure there's a
line open well I'm not saying that that
it would have helped okay but no time to
no use in crying if as if i get to each
form okay okay let's secure this if i
get to age 4 i'm still meeting him with
the Queen not not sure how to how to but
can try probably I should should go here
I'll sop8 if i move the night this
always rookie aid
time warner's I didn't see that at all
check Wow yeah this was a bad game a
really bad game I didn't make anything
of my chances and I had some i'm pretty
sure not like a window or something but
didn't didn't really check check Oh
check yeah well c'mon it's it's black
for offense on time yeah i just wanted
to resign you have a word to say this is
a very sharp line yeah probably i'm
busted around here but those positions
always look like like it's busted and
then he's got a deadly attack all of a
sudden he had the same
very very difficult I mean one thing is
clear that when this is winning what can
even take aid but yeah yeah I completely
forgot about this mess which basically
ends the game I don't get to take on h4
at any point and therefore this is
winning and white probably wins with
other moves as well but this is really
am shutting it down yeah I think
something like this is some
theoretically known hard to save
yeah very tricky to analyze maybe I
should just take now you can take with
the Queen now I don't really believe in
that maybe I'm something already went
wrong it's possible maybe some other
move here not Bishop f8 it looks very
logical but maybe I should just should
play them something like g3 or something
no this is of course a very debatable
move and after h3 the idea is to take
then we've got this one or queen CA 2 h
3 it's very tricky stuff yeah white
should play something else maybe capture
compounds to take here and gives why the
winning advantage oh now it says that
black is winning I was just about to say
that I don't believe in it I came okay
then I probably need to play g3 now it's
calculating Queen see to enter but this
should always give me some play if white
plays a slow move like that she can also
just take and always have some chance to
see em yeah the comp takes a while to
recognize all this stuff for human it's
pretty clear this is a dangerous move
but the compound only sees this after a
couple of seconds yeah this is a very
very complicated stuff he played a good
game I guess very well played thanks for
watching